nestled high in the swiss alps there's a
tiny village
it's got all the things you might expect
in a quaint mountain community chalets
breathtaking views
cable cars
but there's one thing
you might not expect
paragliders
the people who live here love to
paraglide they love it so much that some
even commute to work on a paraglider
even their dogs love to paraglide okay
at least one dog anyway in fact around
10 percent of village residents are
active paragliders
welcome to vacuran switzerland
meet marie she's a village resident who
naturally loves to paraglide
village
swiss
[Music]
and boy do they fly
some
think it would be faster just to hop in
your car
think again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but it's not only sharing the skies with
her best friend and fellow vardhorn
paragliders that keep marie flying
the sensations
[Music]
just
[Music]
hey everybody my name is drew beebe and
i'm here in my terrible home studio that
i've made during quarantine and i wanted
to tell you about our new podcast called
great big story it's got more surprising
and delightful stories just like this
one so head over to apple podcast to
spotify wherever you get your favorite
podcasts and download great big story